certainty is is I think a false goal and
we're not achieving what we're achieving
functional certainties in science and in
just the in our in our day-to-day lives
I mean it's a functional certainty that
I'm sitting here talking to you though
it's possible I could be dreaming or you
know deceived by an evil demon those
kinds of philosophical epistemological
worries don't really relate too much to
the ordinary practice of science the
very useful practice of science and our
ordinary task of just negotiating our
lives and finding happiness in this
world we recognize that there's a reign
there's a continuum of you know I'm not
sure you know it's a coin toss 50/50
understanding of circumstance two being
functionally certain about what is so
and many people are pretending to be
functionally certain or believe
themselves to be functionally certain
about things like Jesus is going to come
back and judge the world in their
lifetime 20% of the American population
claims to be functionally certain that
that is going to come to pass and
seventy-eight percent think that Jesus
going to come back sometime not
necessarily in their lifetime and these
certainties do real work for us I mean
the person who is certain that the soul
enters the zygote at the moment of
conception is the person who wants to
veto stem-cell research
despite the fact that tens of millions
of people are suffering conditions which
for which stem-cell research is the best
line of research to generate therapies
so these these are ideas that are not
just of academic interest or personal
private spiritual relevance I mean these
are these are shaping policies they're
shaping a national conversation and then
when you look to the Muslim world they
are causing people to blow themselves up
on street corners